so the day after the midterm election
last week I said in pretty clear terms
and after spending more time thinking
about it over the weekend feel even more
strongly that these next two years are
going to be some of the biggest in my
lifetime for sure in terms of
determining the future of the political
direction of the United States and
definitely the most important two years
since I've been doing this show
absolutely no question about it and I
was delighted that I was contacted
recently in the context of everything
that's going on in our country and
around the world I was contacted by
longtime member and supporter kaya
who's been a member since 2014 and she
contacted me and she said David I love
the show my mom loves the show we want
to do something to help the show and
help progressive media we want to make a
donation what if we sponsor some
half-price memberships and I said of
course let's do it and I got their
donation in the mail late last week and
it turns out that it's not just two
generations of David Pakman show viewers
and supporters in kaya's family it's not
just kaya and her mom it's kaya and her
mom and her son all three of whom are
fans of the show and I got a great
drawing from her son Gabriel who drew
this interpretation of one of our
Patriot male graphics that show up at
the beginning of hatred mail Gabriel did
this awesome
I absolutely love it and it's so cool
that you sent this to me Gabriel I got a
really great card from kaya as well this
was this was just a fantastic thing to
get I got a really great card from kaya
which said and let me actually read it
because it's just so great hey David
hope you enjoy the fan mail my son drew
it for you I helped a little
I've been indoctrinating him with
liberal propaganda just kidding we
appreciate you so much I've loved being
a member of your show and will continue
to do so and then I also got a really
nice donation check from kaya's mom
Kathy and a really great note from Kathy
as well which says David I'd love to
sponsor new members to your show your
show is so informative the guests are so
interesting especially Professor Richard
wolf I agree he's one of my favorites
she said I also always look forward to
the hey treat male segments keep up the
good work
Kathy and indeed Kathy has sent an
extraordinarily generous check
contribution sponsoring half of 33
memberships ok so Kathy and kaya and
Gabriel together three generations of
viewers have sponsored 33 memberships
they've already paid half of 33
memberships which are normally $60 a
year they've paid $30.00 already that
means that 33 people who don't currently
have memberships can get a $60
membership merely by paying the other 30
dollars okay
kaya and her mom and her son have
already paid $30.00 for you and by
paying $30 you get a $60 membership I am
personally handling these okay I have 33
of these available
please make Gabriel and everybody and
his mom and his grandma proud here email
me david at david pakman.com or you can
use the contact form at david pakman.com
either way I am your personal membership
concierge I'm so excited I'm punching my
microphone let's do these contributions
just this 33 half-price memberships are
available if you agree that these next
two years are just so important you now
have an opportunity to lock in a 50%
discount off of your membership and
support independent media let's not let
the donations go to waste this is how we
turn that donation into twice as many
dollars for the show and you can keep
that discounted rate as long as you want
first-come first-served david at david
pakman.com email me
thanks to kya and her family just
amazing this is this is just great and
I'm so inspired by the support and the
the messages and the great Patriot mail
drawing from